how would you feel if all your daughters
out there [__] every top named rapper
um
i don't know why i don't know i i i'm
like daughter go live your life but
there's something about it to me that's
us all right yeah
because that [__] is
dysfunctional
yes
so it's like
you know if you already got a shady pass
and [__] with the wrong dudes i'm
already looking at you funny
but if you're doing it with famous
people you announcing to everybody that
you love dysfunctional you know what i
mean yeah there's something weird about
that yeah i'm just gonna i would feel
like i [__] up and it ain't got no
nothing to do with the sexual liberation
or whatever or not you can do whatever
you want to do it's the process of how
you do it you know you have to be with
us
so i would just feel like i failed yeah
something like that
if my daughter was just [__] a bunch
of famous youtubers i'd be like i failed
yes yeah yeah it ain't got nothing to do
with like i rather
you
[__]
if you [__] i know she's [__] a whole
bunch of [__] but a whole bunch
of randoms i wouldn't care if you
specifically go for famous [__]
all the time i'd be like
that's weird and me being famous and now
your name ends up in some diss tracks
priest got a daughter i banged that
you know what i mean
i don't want like my name coming up here
if i come up into youtube roast i mean
imagine a fresh and fit find out my
daughter out here getting ran through by
youtubers yeah and fresh feel like yo
amber
i'm like dad these [__] got me
if if your daughter becomes a
verb you got britney rennard goddamn i
failed i [__] failed
oh yeah you lori rving [__]
i failed there's some [__] if you become
a verb it's just one dude okay it's just
youtube it's just youtubers that sucks
that's us that's super success
yeah i feel like i would yeah
i would know a name of a woman who
[__] bill bird dave chappelle
richard pry like you [__] all them
guys across different generations like
i'mma look at you funny
you know what i'm saying
like how you hopping all this top
community
[Music]
i don't know but i digress you're a
top-tier community dick that's right all
this is something [__] all they say
will seem if you have a daughter just be
careful
i don't i don't have those veneers so i
don't know
it's like kim kardashian you don't think
her dad was just like ah this [__] he
killed himself did he
even kill himself oh damn i appreciate
cancer right yeah cancer okay maybe he's
the one who got oj maybe maybe maybe
maybe maybe all that deception gave him
cancer yeah that's how that's how that
family got rich yeah dude's just a
really good lawyer
yeah yeah
isn't him that said
right if the gloof was that alan
dershowitz is that his name
no no no that's um another one of oj's
lawyers okay yeah because they were a
team that was a team was it was it a
black guy in the the armenian dude it
was a team it was a whole team that was
dershowitz it was some it was the black
dude i forgot his name the black dude
said if if the glove don't fit you must
have quit that was the black the black
because you know why spit lyrics like
that you know it was
it was you know it was not the armenian
dude it was a black dude because yeah
yeah you don't know that you're talking
[__] i'd be like your client's
probably still guilty but bars yeah
if i'm on the jury i'll just say yeah if
the armenian dude would have wouldn't
spit that that thing you would have sang
it i don't think you trust in the
judicial system or some [__] like that
you know like armenian people would do
no army people like guys guys
guys
oj didn't do this but my people suffered
a chance
i would like the judge to acknowledge
who was it that does that to the the
armenians the turks the church
the turks yeah